j'avais capacité en chantant
comment dire à pas sentir un peu comme
anesthésié c'est comme si la musique
pensait m'est blessures
et nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20 octobre ce soir Malika
bell'aribi le moral
alors Malika
vous êtes né dans un bidonville de
Nanterre vous avez grandi dans la misère
dans les coups dans les humiliations
et à l'âge de 3 ans a été écrasé par un
camion
vous avez survécu à 10 ans d'opérations
et de rééducation et c'est la musique
qui vous a sauvé aujourd'hui vous êtes
cantatrice vous chantez dans les plus
grandes salles et surtout vous faites
partager votre passion à des femmes et
des enfants des quartiers pauvres on
vous surnomme la divadicité
[Musique]
Malika Bella RIB le mot al re bonsoir
du bidonville de Nanterre vous êtes né
au plus grandes scènes où vous chantez
de l'Opéra aujourd'hui vous avez vécu un
extraordinaire destin que nous allons
raconter alors Malika vous êtes venu au
monde le 3 juillet
1956 votre père est épicé votre mère et
femme au foyer il y a 9 enfants à la
maison et vous vivez tous au milieu du
bidonville des pâquerettes à Nanterre
dans une baraque de 10 mètres carrés à
l'époque y venait tous dans le cadre de
la guerre d'Algérie et ben tout le monde
travaillait pour la France puisqu'on
faisait
alors un jour votre mère vous emmène
faire des courses elle s'arrête pour
vous acheter des sandales elle discute
avec le marchand sans faire attention à
vous et vous vous suivez un rayon de
soleil
qui vient de la rue vous sortez la tête
en l'air en admirant le ciel et soudain
plus rien vous venez de vous faire
écraser par un camion roulant en marche
arrière vous avez trois ans en fait je
jouais sur le trottoir j'ai compris
après que c'était des j'aimais bien ces
petites pierres grises qui brillaient
par le soleil et puis après le noir les
gens mais le bassin fracturé et au
réveil à l'hôpital de Nanterre vous
entendez une infirmière dire cette
petite elle remarchera jamais quoi ouais
c'est vrai j'ai cru que je pourrai
jamais m'en sortir alors à l'hosto
personne ne vient vous voir niveau frère
niveau sœur ni votre mère
et vous regardez le ciel en vous
chantant des chansons
alors un jour on frappe à la porte de
votre chambre une dame entre elle a une
longue robe bleue avec une coiffe
blanche et elle vous dit bonjour Malika
je suis soeur Marguerite
une bonne sœur vous emmène à la messe de
Noël dans la chapelle de l'hôpital et là
vous entendez pour la première fois de
votre vie le Salvé Regina
[Musique]
c'est beau c'est la révélation là et dès
lors vous allez chanter avec les
religieux
alors les opérations se succèdent pour
réparer vos eaux brisées ça vous fait un
mal terrible l'autre mal c'est quand
vous rentrez à la maison et que vous
voyez votre père cogner sur votre Mère
la culture malheureusement maghrébine et
on aime taper les femmes
s'ensuit la tournée des maisons de
convalescence alors là c'est terrible
vous quittez votre famille vous allez à
Cannes
à Cannes parmi les filles en uniforme
vous êtes la fille du biceau oui mais ça
ça va c'était par rapport à ce que
j'avais enduré
alors en Bretagne
vous êtes obligé de voler la soupe du
chien pour bouffer d'abord elle était
très bonne parce qu'elle était avec du
lait du pain mais comme nous on n'avait
pas toujours à manger et je trouvais
qu'elle était bonne à 9 ans vous ne
savez toujours pas lire écrire et
compter
après 9 ans d'aller-retour entre
l'hôpital de Nanterre et ses maisons de
convalescence vous êtes guéri vous
remarcher
à la maison votre père est mort et la
famille est sans ressources votre mère
est obligé de faire des ménages
mais vous êtes 10 la fin s'installe
quand même là un peu dur difficile
à l'école vous devenez la risée de la
classe la tête de turc on vous appelle
handicapé fille de [__] ou débile
mental ben parce qu'envoyait mes
cicatrices à l'époque et le temps il
pensait que j'avais des jambes sales la
cruauté des enfants est incommensurable
alors le champ devient votre refuge vous
vous évadez en vous remémorant les
cantiques que vous entendiez à l'église
avec les religieuses et vous dites à ce
moment-là
quand ma voix s'élève j'oublie les coups
et les humiliations je me lave dans la
musique comme on se lave dans une autre
épée
en chantant
comment dire à pas sentir un peu comme
anesthésié c'est comme si la musique
pensait mes blessures parce que personne
ne le sait en fait à l'époque c'est que
souvent vous rendez à l'église de votre
quartier pour prier j'allais à l'église
parce que quand je recevais des coups ça
paraît débile mais je me plaignais à
Jésus et il me défendait ça peut
paraître bizarre
Marie et Jésus c'était mes amis je vous
décidais de fuguer la durer quelques
semaines vous devenez femme de chambre
dans un hôtel en Touraine 4 étoiles et
je vais une patronne qui était très
sympa qui m'a beaucoup aidé
au retour votre mère et vos frères vous
accueille en vous insultant c'est à dire
que vous êtes parti donc vous êtes une
traînée
leur seule question c'est est-ce que tu
as perdu ta virginité pendant cet
épisode oui parce que quand on est
vierge on peut être marié on est un peu
comment dire on veut des sous et là en
fait vous dites bon ben cette virginité
il m'emmerde je vais la perdre vous
faites ça avec un camarade de classe un
peu comme une formalité Malika oui pour
m'en débarrasser comme ça c'était sûr
que je serais pas vendre
cette perte de virginité n'empêche pas
votre mère d'essayer de vous marier de
force en Algérie et ça vous tend un
piège en Algérie et quand vous êtes en
Algérie en fait vous découvrez qu'elle
veut vous marier quand même elle est
préparée et préparer son coup j'ai perdu
ma virginité le mec va jamais me vouloir
et là elle vous dit c'est pas grave le
soir de la nuit de noce des petits bouts
de verre dans le là tu vas saigner et le
mec pensera que tu es vierge et c'est là
que je lui ai dit que je la dénoncerai
devant tout le monde et elle avait peur
voilà elle a lâché finalement vous
rentrez en France et là vous êtes perdu
vous rencontrez un marchand de tableau à
Montmartre un enfant avec lui le couple
ne dure pas et là votre sœur Hayate se
suicide faites des cauchemars à partir
de là vous avez des hallucinations vous
allez voir un psy
un jour
la psy vous demande qu'est-ce que vous
avez vraiment envie de faire Malika dans
la vie vous répondez du théâtre mais il
faudrait qu'il y ait de la musique aussi
et une belle histoire et la psy vous dit
mais ça existe ça s'appelle l'opéra et
en fait c'est comme ça que c'est arrivé
c'est génial
un soir d'hiver alors que vous chantez
dans la chorale de la mairie du 18e vous
sentez votre voix s'élevée
et son envol vous donnait une sensation
de puissance vous comprenez vraiment que
vous avez quelque chose en vous qui
dépasse tout le reste et là je me suis
dit c'est mon espace ma liberté je peux
m'exprimer
à partir de là vous intégrez des écoles
de chant de plus en plus réputés c'est
incroyable d'ailleurs vous montez très
très vite dans des endroits c'est des
milliers d'heures de travail et puis
pour comprendre les textes que vous
chantez parce que comme ils sont en
allemand ou en italien vous êtes obligé
d'apprendre l'allemand et l'italien
chaque fois que vous sentez le miracle
se produit Malika la petite arabe
devient une héroïne de Verdi ou de Bizet
et là alors que tout le monde vous voit
déjà sur la scène de l'Opéra de Paris ou
la Scala de Milan il y a un nouveau
rebondissement dans votre destin une
amie vous propose de monter un opéra en
banlieue avec des femmes maghrébines
en fait j'ai chanté à Gavot et elle est
venue me voir au concert et elle m'a
demandé de venir à Creil donc j'ai
chanté et là elle m'a demandé de
réfléchir à un projet quelques mois plus
tard vous réédité l'expérience avec des
enfants et un jour une petite
cambodgienne vous dit je suis contente
parce que la nuit quand j'ai peur je
chante dans ma tête et ça fait fuir le
bruit des bombes
[Musique]
alors ma Lyca on peut vous voir dimanche
le 14 décembre avec votre spectacle La
Belle Hélène à 15h30 à l'espace 93 à
Clichy-sous-Bois
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu